can I be honest  oh I think I could suck better than I  eat  [Laughter]  for real why are you tapping  yeah  it's logical you know what you like not  just that but his cheek looks like he  got some Vortex suction power you might  not know how to tease the dick  but you got that rough ass weight  lifting hands I could put the lotion on  make it smooth I'm sure there's some guy  out there that's like I volunteer for  tribute comment below if you want to  volunteer you could be the experiment  dude that's a hell of a joke  hey I really want to know who out there  is down to get your [ __ ] dick you  gotta have like bars blown up Men's  Health magazine photo shoot all up on  the wall oh the naked one next to that  photo  I'm better at sucking dick